why are artists never happy
I mean you know where do you start where
do you start you know there's so many
I've I've always said that I'd rather
get the joke than be
just uh the butt of it you know so I'd
rather get the joke you know and I feel
like getting the joke comes with
some sense of deprecation some sense of
uh nihilism you know
um the
irony of the world and the way it works
is is just a part of most artists
because
I mean we're I mean especially in the
Hollywood version of this
um I mean I suppose it applies to
everybody actually you know you're
constantly dancing for someone that
isn't really even interested in knowing
there's a show going on you know you're
trying to do this thing which you meet
other people to help Elevate you know
the career and to continue to work and
all that stuff how could you not be
depressed how could you not be sad when
you're constantly being dulled uh you're
not handsome enough you're not tall
enough you're not funny enough you're
not dramatic enough or in your writing
you can't do this your scripts are too
small or your scripts are too big or you
know you don't write dialogue that well
or you don't
structure things that well hey the point
is everybody's got an opinion and
unfortunately as artists we are in the
position of listening or being told all
of those opinions this is why I always
tell young people never to read the
comments because the truth is everybody
in this world gets an opinion on movies
everybody does they're movie stars that
I just don't like the way they look
their face bugs me I don't like them as
movie stars that's me I get to do that
right it's not fair that person has done
nothing to me but I am that for somebody
else and it's just a lot to put on the
uh on the table of like this is all
stuff that you were inspiring with your
work some of it's fantastic some of it's
not
I mean wow it's there's a lot to carry
around with that but you also have to
think that's where the ego comes from
too right the ego is or the sometimes
narcissism is a direct result of the
fact that you know we we just feel
insecure and uh
in what's the right word uh not worthy
of the the job because the job is
awesome like when the job is popping on
all cylinders and you're doing the thing
whether it's writing a movie that is
financed and you're getting paid for
amazing amazing and you're part of the
process of making this film or you're
directing something where you know the
the Stars show up and they look to you
and they say
what should I do boss you know or you're
acting for somebody you know all of it
is so cool there's nothing I'd rather do
with my life the downside is we have to
deal with
um the depression that comes with
chasing that dragon and sometimes it
fulfills and sometimes it doesn't you
miss out on jobs you get the job you do
the job the job's over okay I'm sad
again
these are just things that happen I
think uh with the kind of person who is
willing to get up in front of people and
create something new because I think it
takes a lot of hutzpah it takes a lot of
courage to be like this is my
performance this is my script this is my
movie and I believe in this and now I'm
going to put it out there for you and I
hope you like it too
um but that has to balance out somehow
and it rarely balances out with
well-adjusted happy people
what range of emotions do you typically
experience on a project if there was an
evolution of a project
seed of the idea
you start working on it
show it to people Workshop it gets
accepted
you know if it was like a circle right
yeah uh okay I mean I think all of them
you know it's like in prep right before
you're on the ground and getting to
actually work on something you know if
we're talking about directing
specifically directing is you get to go
through the entire process right where
you the script is
um it comes alive whether or not I write
it or whether there's another writer
that writes it and I'm overseeing it
before boots on the ground is the worst
for me that's the time of anxiety and
anger because it's all about emails not
being responded it's all about you know
this is not a priority yet for anybody
except for you right you're the only
person who's six weeks out cares right
we don't have cast we don't have sets we
don't have uh locations probably but we
have to put all the pieces together to
try to make this happen and it's it's so
frustrating to be trying to do that and
you know you're just not hearing back
from anybody for three days like that's
just at the best case scenario and then
if you start making offers to talent
that far out they're not getting back to
you for weeks right so you you try to be
proactive you try to make the movie
um sing right you try to make it go as
easily as possible because the more you
prepare the better off you are the more
you prepare the better off you are but
you can't do these things by yourself
you need a team of people and they're
not there yet so that's where I'm the
most neurotic and crazy is is in those
prep days
um when we're on boots on the ground
um I hate I was just talking about this
the other day I hate scouting it's very
important you have to do it you have to
do it it's very important but I hate it
it's so boring it's always always
awkward because you've got like five to
ten people who are going with you and
then you're trying you know somebody's
gonna give you or rent you this place
for probably not much money so you have
to kind of Kiss Ass a little bit and be
nice and everything and then
if you decide you don't like it you have
to kind of be you know curtained you
know we'll talk later it's like and then
you go outside and everybody hates
everything and so I don't like it I
don't like the process and it usually
takes a full freaking like 15 hours you
know of like going all over creation
nothing's close to each other anyways
I'm just bitching now because the fact
is is that it's the greatest job in the
world so once cast is there once we're
making the movie I'm my best self I've
always felt that
um that I enjoy it more than
um seems rational but that doesn't mean
that I don't have bad days or I don't
get frustrated or I don't you know get
concerned
um you know we we just had
um uh I just filmed this movie called
Miss Valentine that uh will be coming
out next year and we had this scene
where I had the actress running up and
down these steps you know uh outside of
a big theater and it's thematic for the
movie it's important for the movie
um but she Twisted her ankle and I'm
like that that level of fear you know
not just for the project right because I
mean if she breaks an ankle like I'm in
trouble right but for her who has put
her trust in me to you know run up and
down these steps a million times because
I tell her I need it right
um so that level of paternal concern and
you know fear for them of like you know
it's just so much it's I always think of
directing as having this paternal you
know feeling about everybody of like you
know uh it's a family and you need to be
the the person that keeps it on track
you need to set the tone but also if
there's trouble you have to be the one
that deals with the trouble like first
off
um but the truth is it's the greatest
job so I like it I you know even though
it's ups and downs and ups and downs the
worst part is truly when it's all over
when it's like okay
now I have to start thinking about the
next job and the next job and the next
job and I'm still kind of hung up on
this job because
um you know hopefully if it goes well
it's like a family at the end of the day
not just because of your responsibility
but because you have put all these
people here to do a job and hopefully
they all excel at it and then you love
them all the more for doing the job that
you ask them to do well
um it's it's it's great I I really do
like it but it's all the emotions all of
them
uh that usually the the one that I don't
feel is um
I never feel sorry for myself because uh
even when I get frustrated or angry I'm
like I'm still directing a movie which
is
better than what I would be doing today
anyways you know what I mean
do you give yourself permission to feel
sad for maybe like a week after
everything ends yeah sure I I do I I
feel like I uh
people worry about me in that aspect but
I always I'm like I take care of me like
if I want to uh go out to eat because
I'm depressed I go out to eat you know
if I want to stay at home I do that
um I feel like I don't
I enjoy life I feel like life is um
it's for the living we're only here for
a short time
I like to uh sup the marrow as it goes
uh so if I want to be sad today then
that's what I'm going to do you know um
and I feel like that's okay I mean you
know I my fiance and I we don't have
kids or anything like that there's
nobody who's banging on the door being
like I need to be fed so if I just want
to take a day
that's what I do that's what and I think
it's good and healthy for people to do
that especially after a movie because
movies are 12 hours minimum usually 15
hours a day we did six day weeks on this
last film
um I didn't sleep at all
um one of the but also I had a great
time with the cast and crew after my job
was done we were all staying at the
whole same hotel and we would you know
have drinks and stay up and talk and and
I had a great time and then I had to get
up the next day with three hours sleep
and do it again
and I still feel like I was just so
lucky just to be there so you were
almost repeating what you saw at that
Motel 6 and that you were seeing these
interesting conversations absolutely and
it was like it came to life for you 20
years later I hope so I mean I hope so I
I like to think that I try to be those
people
um the the people that were there for me
when I was a kid you know I try to be
for my cast and crew I feel like that's
kind of the deal of being the director
and
um it's not just the movie the movie is
the most important thing and that makes
life a lot easier when you think about
it like that like
the movie's the most important thing but
it's not the only thing right this
experience these um six weeks that we're
spending together are going to be the
memories that I carry around you know
this is the our special time of being
financed to sit here and do art you know
and whether I raise the money or the
money was you know brought on by my
bosses or whatever we have this window
to create a movie I mean come on that is
like
there's no reason for that to be a bad
experience
um I understand that it's not all uh you
know balloons and pizza you know
sometimes there's problems sometimes you
have to deal with those problems
sometimes there's conflict that's innate
to creating something but the movie
shouldn't be
a a nightmare you know uh and you know
that that movie that I made manic was um
I was proud of that movie the way it
came out I think the director did a fine
job but every day on set was awful it
was an awful day you know and we would
get out of set and I would just want to
drink and but like aggressively not like
fun like I'm just I was so unhappy and I
just never want to be that person's be
any talents movie or crew or anything I
don't want them to look back on
Cupid for Christmas and be like Oh What
A bear that thing was you know I was
like no we had a good time we laughed
and you know we worked long hours and we
did
things that were challenging but at the
end of the day we're proud of what we
made we're proud of the the bond that we
built and the the time that we spent